المساعدات التي تم تجميعها في قاعده انجرك
العسكريه التركيه والموجهه الى المناطق
المنكوبه بالزلزال سيتم تحميلها على هذه
الطائرات المروحيه وهذه الطائرات هي جزء
من مجموعه اكبر من الطائرات تتوجه الى
المناطق المنكوبه البعيده والتي لا تستطيع
ربما الشاحنات الوصول اليها هذه الطائرات
تحلق بمعدل 60 الى 70 طلعه جويه وسطيا في
اليوم سنحاول ان نكون على متن واحده من
هذه الطائرات بعد قليل
تعتبر قائده انجرليك المركز الاساسي لنقل
المساعدات الى المناطق المتضرره جراء
الزلزال هذه المساعدات هي قادمه من دول
مختلفه وايضا هي مساعدات قادمه من المدن
التركيه غير المتضرره يتم تصنيف هذه
المساعدات وتنظيمها من قبل الجيش التركي
نحن هنا علمتني احدى المروحيات التي تنقل
المساعدات الى المناطق المنكوبه بالزلزال
هذه الطلعات الجويه يتم تنسيقها بين اداره
الطوارئ والطوارئ التركيه ووزاره الدفاع
التركيه يتم اختيار المناطق وفق حاجتها
القصوى يتم نقل ايضا المساعدات المختلفه
هذه المساعدات عباره عن خيم لوازم اطفال
وكل ما يمكن ان يحتاجه
المتضررون جراء زلزال سواء كان مواد طبيه
او مواد اضافيه كما ان هذه المروحيات لا
تنقل فقط المساعدات تنقل ايضا
طواقم المؤسسات الرسميه التي تحاول
الاعتناء بالمواطنين الذين تضرروا جراء
الزلزال
وصلنا الى هذه المنطقه في محافظه هاتاي
المروحيه ستنزل حمولتها هنا ومن ثم ستعود
الى قاعده في اضنه للتزود بمزيد من
المساعدات ونقلها الى مناطق منكوبه اخرى
المعتز بالله حسن الجزيره